as you can see this is weird and awkward
so we want a better way
to write this right every new form of
notation you ever learned
was just because we're trying to solve a
problem something which is awkward and
weird to write
okay so what we're going to do is we're
going to try and stop writing
negative numbers under square roots
because it gives me the heebie-jeebies
we're going to introduce what we call
an imaginary unit the most basic
negative number
that you can take a square root of is
negative 1.
we call this the imaginary unit every
other
imaginary number is made up of these
guys right
for example to get square root of
negative 3 you multiply this
by the square root of 3. do you agree
if i did this i'd get that and in order
to stop doing this because i'm you're
going to write this a heck of a lot
right
we give this a name we call it i for
imaginary
okay so i could rewrite my solutions
here
if you like as not minus 1 plus or minus
this guy
but instead
minus one there's the real part plus
or minus some number of these and i said
before it was root three
of them there's the real part there's
the imaginary part you put them together
you get a complex number
make sense okay now we have just enough
time to explore just a teeny bit
of how these numbers play how they're a
little bit different
to your normal numbers and then you guys
are going to do some work
all the way up until friday okay so make
a little subheading which is arithmetic
all right get rid of this
[Applause]
okay so um
a few basic facts first now we've
established the existence of this eye
thing the square root of negative 1. we
want to just establish
what this thing can do right so if
that's what i is
then if for example and i'm going to
write all this up the top again just so
i have it in a neater spot
if i were to say multiply i by itself
then by definition i squared
should give you 1 negative 1. so in the
past we would have said there's no
number that you can square
to get a negative number but that's
because we didn't have the complete
picture yet we do
now more than you even realize this is
the complete picture
um what happens if i do it again if i
multiply by i
another time negative well yeah it's
minus one
right that's that's i squared
times i again so that's negative i is
that that okay
right you can do this one more time
if i multiply by i a fourth time
you're taking this and multiplying by i
so this is i
cubed times i we just established that
that's minus i
times i so what does this become one
yeah it's it's one because you've got a
negative one here
and then these guys become negative one
negative one times negative one one
weird that contemplate this for a little
while we'll return to this idea of
cycling through i on friday morning
but then you just need to know what the
rest of the operations are right
we've done this sort of cycling through
what about addition
well thankfully if you were to add two
complex numbers and we can prove this if
you like
if i've got as a complex number z by the
way z is our customary way of defining
that we're talking about a complex
number not just a real number
i'm putting a dash through it because if
you write a z fast and you write it a
lot
it looks a heck of a lot like a two so
bad idea
dash through it means that if i were to
add
a number which has a real component and
an imaginary component
with some other number that had its own
real component
and its own imaginary component
what happens
you don't need to write this part but if
i gave you
something like this which you're pretty
comfortable with
what happens when you add x and y in
this case
any takers in more than a murmur what do
we do with the one and the two
you're adam right so the rational parts
they just go together
what about the other bits they also
add right these irrational parts i can't
quite mix them together
with these guys right but that's okay i
sort of just keep them separate and they
do their own thing
right it's the same deal with these guys
right we're going to
add these real components and then we're
going to add the
imaginary components so what do we get
well in this case z plus w
you're going to get these real bits out
the front
and then you're going to get these
imaginary bits out the back
i'm going to factor out the imaginary
unit because that's kind of why
we use it this makes sense so if i if i
solved out all these root 3s for
i's it would look exactly the same 1
plus i
2 plus 4i you would add them and get 3
plus 5i
okay i hope you can prove yourself
that subtraction will be the same you've
actually already done
some multiplication there's just one
last piece
of arithmetic that you need which is a
little trickier than all the rest
addition subtraction multiplication
division
we'll go with this example what if i
told you to
divide uh what did i give you this
these guys together what do i do with
this
now if your emotional response was yeah
i just
oh that's that's how i felt the first
time i met these right
i was like i'm i'm a good mathematician
i can do dividing numbers
we actually need a tool from back over
here to help us
right if i asked you to divide these two
you'd run into the same problem
because this irrational stuff makes
things messy do you agree
it's it's gross right like what do i
deal with this you've got the same
problem here
if you're trying to get rid of
irrational stuff what do we call that
particularly when it's on like a
denominator what do you call it when you
get rid of the irrational stuff we call
it rationalizing denominators and we
rational
we learn this skill in year 9 so that we
can handle stuff like this
well we're not rationalizing here we're
trying to make some
something not imaginary we're trying to
make it real
so instead of calling it rationalizing
we're going to call it
realizing now the same trick that we use
with rationalizing will work
with realizing did you notice when we
did this guy here alpha beta
right you put two complex numbers
together but suddenly
in the end it's rubbed off you ended up
with a completely real number did you
see that right ended up with four
what do i multiply the top and the
bottom by
that will realize this denominator for
me what do we call it starts with a c
the conjugate right it's 2 2
minus 4 i and 2 minus 4 i we're not
actually changing the fraction do you
agree
so let's go ahead and we'll just quickly
work out what this lands on i'll work
out the
numerator in a minute let's just think
about the denominator
a plus b a minus b
think for a moment what's a squared
oh it's 4. i'm going to take away b
squared but what is b squared
it's 4i squared
right what happens to the 4 when i
square it 16. what happens to the i
when i square it negative negative 1
minus 16. you with me
got it so you see difference of squares
right a squared minus b squared
is what you get when you're in real
numbers but actually with complex
numbers
you actually get a sum of squares that's
a bit weird isn't it
i think you guys can handle the rest in
the numerator like we did here